la oportunidad de estar acá
y estoy agradecido
de que
esta espontánea estaría espontánea de
reunirnos para poder discutir Bueno
estoy muy agradecido de verdad y
Quisiera darle las gracias al casillero
por tomarse el tiempo de estar aquí
también
al presidente he querido presidente
querido canciller queridos generales
estoy realmente feliz de estar acá
para fortalecer
la unidad continental y por supuesto
agradecer personalmente
una persona muy importante
una figura importante la vida política
tenemos que estar agradecidos tenemos
que ser sinceros Además así es como se
crean alianzas
Esto es lo que cimienta nuestra Alianza
damas y caballeros ustedes saben que
Francia y Alemania han estado del lado
de Ucrania en el último año hemos
atravesado muchas situaciones peligrosas
juntos desde el febrero anterior
y hemos podido lograr una fuerte unidad
la unidad de Europa nos ha fortalecido
quisiera estar solo unos cuantos
ejemplos
de la historia reciente
ejemplos de liderazgo de Manuel macronel
fue uno de los primeros en respaldar a
Ucrania
con vehículos armados ligeros por su
parte no se ha respaldado con armas
vitales para detener el terror ruso
y Estos son solamente dos de muchos
pasos históricos por los cuales quiero
agradecerle a ustedes amigos por tomar
actualmente en Ucrania
Estamos en guerra
y el momento es el tiempo es importante
es esencial
las próximas semanas y los próximos
meses
debemos actuar
necesitamos armamento para lograr la paz
porque debemos de tener esta guerra de
agresión iniciada por Rusia y como se
dijo también
tenemos hemos tenido unos encuentros
apropiados
los encuentros de normandía nos dieron a
creer que podíamos de tener la agresión
rusa pero ya vemos los resultados con el
fin de fortalecer nuestra posición
conjunta
necesitamos mucho más respaldo
Francia y Alemania
pueden ser
jugadores que cambien este juego Estas
son las discusiones que tendremos hoy
Ucrania necesita
obtener misiles de largo alcance
necesitamos
aviones modernos de combate y
necesitamos entrenamiento para
manejarlos
necesitamos vehículos armados tanques de
batalla y Tan pronto como recibimos
Estas armas podremos establecer la paz
en Ucrania necesitamos
todo el apoyo de ustedes Emanuel c que
esto es muy importante para usted tener
a Europa fuerte y C Olaf también
que usted también
ha llevado a cabo políticas racionales
para combatir la agresión rusa Y eso es
muy importante para nosotros hoy y
espero que podamos hablar sobre esto con
más detalle a medida que ocurre la
reunión de hoy Ucrania puede ser más
fuerte Ucrania esta agradecida y somos
sinceros creo que fortaleceremos nuestra
unidad en nuestras defensas conjuntas a
través de sanciones tanto como
mejor armamento defensivo Muchas gracias
Gloria Ucrania
me encanta que el presidente macron y yo
tengamos la posibilidad hoy
de discutir y de hablar directamente con
el presidente zelensky
antes de la reunión del Consejo europeo
que ocurrirá mañana Emmanuel macron y yo
también tuvimos un encuentro personal
con el presidente ucraniano junio pasado
en junio pasado cuando viajamos a kiev
ha pasado casi un año y desde entonces
ucrani llevado a cabo una batalla llena
de coraje contra la agresión Rusia rusa
que ha hecho blancos en su población
civil y también ha causado grandes daños
a la infraestructura del país muchos
ucranianos han muerto en esta guerra
muchos más han resultado heridos miles
de personas han huido estas zonas de
combate y han buscado protección en
Polonia en Alemania y en otros países en
toda Europa
por más de 11 meses ya Ucrania y sus
ciudadanos
han mostrado un gran coraje una gran
tenacidad en la defensa ante la agresión
rusa
y les debemos mucho respeto y desde el
inicio de esta guerra atroz
hemos estado del lado de Ucrania junto
con nuestros aliados
y también hemos respaldado Ucrania a
nivel humanitario financiero
y armamentístico con artillería pesada
armamento antiaéreo y también con la
entrega de tanques de batalla y
continuaremos haciéndolo mientras sea
necesario el presidente macron y yo
hemos asegurado que hoy
nuestro interés a medida que hablamos
con el presidente
la invasión del presidente Putin a
Ucrania las consecuencias de esta
invasión
han establecido una ha mandado una señal
bastante fuerte y el hecho de que el
presidente esté participando en este
primer encuentro del Consejo europeo
2023 también es una señal bastante
fuerte es una señal clara para Rusia de
que la familia Europea
desde junio anterior sigue siendo fuerte
y sigue estando del lado de Ucrania
y está cuidando
está estudiando la candidatura a la
Unión Europea por parte de moldavia me
complace muchísimo reunirme aquí
con blody
y con Emmanuel macrón
estamos de lado Ucrania a medida que
defienden su país y defienden los
valores de la solidaridad
la integridad territorial
y todos los valores que defendemos
juntos y Rusia no debe ganar esta guerra
Gracias a todas ahora pasemos a trabajar
Muchas gracias damas y caballeros